how's it going bros mah haah today I
have something very exciting to play
with you go bros u goats oh man I always
used to play come on your tank but
dammit I'm not a tank Rogue rogue is
stealthy and dexterous Oh hunter now
wait magician this is hunter the
microwave are the most evil constructs
involved the world and the next the
purpose in this world is to create a
black hole to consume the entire
universe why has no one tried to stop
them I'm kind of curious about this
microwave thing Wow
oh jesus [ __ ] Mike I don't need to
play horror games I can display this
alright I am microwave I came from that
factory look at that booty hmm you can
just see the tip of the ass cheeks
that's my favorite snowflake Factory
I'm getting XP just standing on dead
goats this is a great game
I have great legs I have great walking
style gotta give it to myself let's try
out our abilities we have number one
which does looks like a pizza
alright very good
so I can pay out pizzas where does the
pizzas come from so many questions can
they do damage whoa get damaged Oh take
that barrel you stinking barrel
I always are Jesus hahahaha I can self
explode and anytime I want
this is the best oh my god I almost said
best game ever but we don't I'm not sure
yet how did you I don't want to just
throw away that title alright
are the what are these peasant coach
taste my pizza you dirty piss it damn up
why do I do that to myself so I can
punch them and I can also back kick them
doesn't seem to work I twerk them oh
Jesus God I'm sorry I'm sorry
alright let's do some quests whoo yay
up [ __ ] damn it maybe I can explode
myself over there there we go great
ability so I don't know if the makers of
this game knows that microwaves aren't
goats I feel like someone should tell
them but damn those spandex though all
right let's do our first quest welcome a
brave soul you must be the hero the
prophecy foretold you are the MarySue
that is meant to save this land from
certain doom oh thank you have a pizza
damnit wrong button again I swear to god
I'm not doing that above it what is she
saying
sorry firstly sorry I missed the story
here have a pizza please tell me the
story god damn it why will no one enjoy
my pizza so what is it bring great to
her soda well how convenient there is a
soda right there press one to save Beryl
to inventory wait I lick with the cable
Jesus okay so it's now in my inventory
and now we have to bring her the soda
great I was so thirsty I thought I was
gonna die umm I think she is oh god what
was that what is she doing here have a
pizza have a pizza and forget your pains
works every time hello Henry is trying
to pretend that he doesn't know what's
going on
don't try to and try to ignore me Henry
that's right you can have a pizza too
why are you trying to run for my pizzas
everyone wants a pizza you want a pizza
everyone wants your pizza oh man I love
this game favorite game ever have a
pizza wallet really you turn into flames
from the pizza come on
right way or wrong way the wrong way
please
Danger Danger ha you can tell a
microwave what to do feel bad that's a
that's Swedish for wrong way but it kind
of sound like a you know like a goat get
it feel bag you don't get it you're not
Swedish enough I'm sorry
just look at my booty and forget your
troubles where were we claim ah fight me
so are those real people I don't
understand I can type hi guys free gold
why can't I do a real cheese this is
stupid
are these real people shadow assassin ha
no one is stupid enough to name
themselves dad unless they're 12 how the
[ __ ] did I get out of here ah all right
right way wrong way let's go right way
this time Dibby Dibby Dibby d can't wait
to see what this beautiful world has to
offer
hey have a pizza are you kidding me ah
I'm starting to get hiccups damn it whoa
this world is so be it big and beautiful
I just want to lick everything the life
of a microwave people don't understand
the struggles no one takes me seriously
all I want to do is give them free pizza
but instead I ought dammit alright that
looks like so there's a quest over here
oh no my distress cousin what are you
doing how are we related I'm a bike
already you know that right
dude you got a hippie a bit stinking
this [ __ ] Paddy's name I've even had you
eat it to survive ha ha please you gotta
get me out of here I'll give you the
only valuables to have what what is your
only valuables alright you know what
have a pizza you ungrateful son of a
[ __ ] there you go
deep [ __ ] I received a piece of [ __ ]
really yeah it's right there
great thanks buddy you piece of [ __ ]
literally best quest ever 10/10 would
play again quests number 2 where are you
hey well Steve Steve works hello Steve
work out
hello mighty hero I'm in dire need of a
heroic being such as yourself I'll stop
it stop it I am a lover of
I hear sound completely Apple s a
travesty so fetch some apples for me
would ya five should be enough for now
you know there's literally apples
everywhere right why would you want an
apple when you can have a Pete's oh I
love this sound when I make a pizza I
like ah wine apple that would be two
apples what the [ __ ] is she doing
Dylan what are you doing buddy there you
go five apples you have truly saved my
life
these aren't words to express there
aren't words to extra Dragutin take this
what I get I got an apple damn it get me
something good for the [ __ ] is this
Winchester's anyway stupid
dammit I swear to God one day one day I
learned to click the right button slap
that ass with a pizza yeah yeah oh you
like it don't you finally damnit never
mind
alright more quest more journeys more
wenches I'm gonna make him come with me
Gustav 'edit sauce Gustavo sauce yes
that a name your name is Gustavo roses
come with me cassava horses we shall
have many adventures and lovely moments
together I never had a friend before I
don't know why maybe because I'm a
[ __ ] microwave but who knows really
you know I'll just put you in my
inventory let's go to the local in hello
this is I yes I am a talking microwave
oh I can't stop thinking about the
mermaid I made the other day her name is
Miranda she's so dreamy but I'm a bit
too shy to go see what the [ __ ] are you
doing she's still at the beach could you
please go talk to her and maybe it's
quarters here alright I'm a microwave I
don't see why you would ask a microwave
to do that but here's a pizza while
you're at it
everyone gets pizza I'm like Oprah you
get a pizza you get a pizza you get a
pizza
everyone gets pizzas everyone gets aids
to deter dude why are you on fire why
are you okay with being on fire look I
have a pizza tail look-look at my
taillights a pizza pizza tail the best
tale I've heard a tale of the pizza
Oh jokes alright where's the beach where
is the beach this is the beach isn't it
now I know you hurt you're wondering how
can a microwave swim actually I'm quite
good at it
where's this mermaid they must be here
somewhere
come on Pizza tail mermaid could be on
the other side what the hell is that
gold Horovitz Gollum doric demon I
better throw pizzas at it where is this
[ __ ] mermaid how am i this good at
swimming wait I level up by swimming yes
I'm [ __ ] level 12 I wonder whether my
first rate is gonna be oh man I would
totally play this I'm not even kidding
I would totally play this MMO just like
if I wish go to a real every night I
wish this game is real alright so
there's a crossing here don't mind me
lads I'm just a microwave don't worry
about it just a microwave looking for a
mermaid nothing to see here
I'm a [ __ ] dolphin look at this [ __ ]
where is this Miranda oh here's a
dolphin no I mean here's the bleach I
always mix it up dolphin the beaches I
don't know wait it's the elfin place oh
my god Bob what are you doing here Bob
Bob wait up damn it Bob is lagging damn
it babe
where is Miranda why is he squeezing his
nipples
what kind of goats are you Jesus did
lost it they lost her mind have a pizza
while you're at it all right we're just
gonna have to kill them it was for the
best
bob is still lagging damn it Bob get
proper in that dammit
all right you know what I'll have to end
the first part there but I hope you
enjoyed watching I had a lot of fun
playing this is pretty [ __ ] awesome
they were like a window watching birds
share this video with your grandma and I
will see you in the next one as always
stay awesome